[Müzik]
Merhabalar bu dünyada bir şeylerin her
şeyin sürekli olarak
geliştiğini ve değiştiğini bilmek hiçbir
şeyin kalıcı olmadığını bilmek büyük bir
huzur veriyor derin bir huzur veriyor
insana Bu farkındalık Aslında bizim
yürüdüğümüz yolu çok daha kolay
yürümemizi sağlıyor
problemleri hesaplanıp kalmadan çok
kolayca ilerleyebiliyoruz
Bugün ben size aslında aynı lüks
robotlarından ya da büyüleyici metalurs
dünyasından ya da gelecekteki büyüleyici
teknoloji teknolojik gelişmelerden
bahsetmeyeceğim bugün problemlere bakış
açımızı değiştirmediğimiz sürece bu
teknolojik gelişmelerin hiçbir manası
olmadığını anlatmak istiyorum Hiçbir
anlamı olmadığından bahsetmek istiyorum
Steve jobs'ın söylediği gibi
bu geleceği öngörmenin en iyi yolu onu
yaratmaktır
3 çocuğunu büyük bir sevgiyle ve emekle
büyütmüş olan
çok güçlü bir annenin ilk çocuğuyum ben
bizim evimizde hiçbir zaman engelliler
olmadı bizim evimizde çözülmesi gereken
problemler olabilirdi o problemler
ortaya atılır ve işbirliği yapılarak
çözümlenmeye çalışılırdı 17 yaşındayım
bir sabah kalktım Yüzümde farklı bir his
var
bu his gün içerisinde daha da arttı
sanki bir hissizlik sonra doktora gittim
doktora gittiğimde doktor bana yüz felci
geçirdiğimi söyledi
arkasının sığınabileceğin çok fazla
gerekçem vardı
17 yaşındayım yüzüm böyle mi kalacak
insanlar hakkımda ne düşünecek yıllarca
bu sınava hazırlandım
nasıl olacak bu büyük bir talihsizlik
gibi birçok gerekçem olabilirdi
Fakat ben bunların hiçbirini düşünmedim
düşündüğüm tek şey o Sınava nasıl
girebilirim sınavdan bir gün önce
ailemle görüştüm tartıştık konuyu ve
beni çok desteklediler sınava girmek
istediğimi söyledim
büyük bir koruma altında Çünkü yüzümü
korumam gerekiyordu sınav salonuna
götürdüm
sınav salonunda gözlerimin bir tanesi
işlevini yitirdiği için ve sadece sağ
gözümle idare etmek zorunda olduğum için
Yüzümün sol tarafını hissetmediğim için
ağzımın Kulaklarıma yaklaştığı için
Sözel soruları Tabii ki yapamayacaktım
zorlanıyordum okumakta sadece sayısal
sorularla o yıl Marmara Üniversitesi
tekstil bölümünü kazandım bu hikayeyi
niye anlattım problemleri bakış açımız
Aslında bizim geleceğimizi inşa ediyor
Eğer problemleri bir engel olarak
görürsek bizim engelimiz oluyor
problemleri bir fırsat olarak görürsek
fırsatlarımız oluyor geleceğimiz çok
daha farklı şekilleniyor
problemlerden bahsetmişken tasarım
odaklı düşünmeye girmek istiyorum
tasarım odaklı düşünme Aslında
problemlere farklı bakış açılarıyla
çözüm üreterek farklı fikirler yürüterek
çözüm üretme metodolojisidir
tasarım odaklı düşünmenin aşamaları var
empati kurma empati kurma Aslında son
kullanıcıya ya da ne üretmek istiyorsak
onun yerine kendimizi koymak
problemi tanımlama problemi tanımlamak
çok kritik bir yaşama Çünkü sabit bir
noktadan tek bir noktadan baktığımızda
problemi tanımlamak çok güç olmaya
başlıyor farklı bakış açılarıyla
baktığımızda çok daha zenginleştiriyoruz
fikir üretme problemi tanımladıktan
sonra araştırma aşaması var araştırma
aşamasında araştırma tekniklerini
biliyor olmak gerçekten çok ciddi bir
avantaj ve sonra fikir üretme aşamasına
geldiğimizde Aslında fikirler tek tek
dökülmeye başlıyor prototiple
prototipleme ve sonrasında test etme
aşaması ve bu aşamalardan sonra eğer
geliştirmemiz gereken bir nokta varsa
yapıyı güçlendiriyoruz
üniversite sınavını kazandım ilk
üniversite sırasına oturdum önümde bir
not defteri not defterine şunu yazdım
bilimin yolundan asla ayrılmayacağım
bunu yazdıran neydi Tabii ki bendeki
bilim tutkusu
Bu bilim tutkusuyla bütün hayatım
boyunca bu cümle Benim Bütün hayatımı
şekillendirdi ve bütün hayatım boyunca
bu şekilde hareket ettim 2011 yılında bu
tutkuyla doktoraya başladım 2012 yılında
aklında bir proje fikri var projemi
hayata geçirmek istiyorum ve bütçe
arıyorum o dönemde bütçe bulmak şu
ankiden çok daha zor bir ilan gördüm
Eğer finale kalırsam
sponsor olabilecekleri yazıyordu bir
yarışma ilanı hemen başvurdum 15 kişilik
bir jürinin önüne çıktım bu 15 kişilik
jürinin içerisinde Sanayiciler ve
akademisyenler vardı oraya gittiğimde
aslında yanlış bir platformda olduğumu
da gördüm Çünkü daha çok diğer projeler
Kısa vadeli ürge projeleriydi benim
projem ise çok daha uzun vadeli bir Arge
projesiydi Çünkü ben bir Tekstil
düzeyinden Elektrik üretmek istiyordum
projeme destek verdiler güçle sağladılar
ve ben o sevinçle aylarca Laboratuvardan
çıkmadım inanılmaz çalıştık malzemeler
ini Tekstil mühendisleri kimya
mühendislerinden oluşan çok Multi
disipliner bir ekiple deli gibi
çalışarak işin sonunda elektrik üretmeyi
başardık fakat ürettiğimiz elektrik çok
küçük bir miktardı 2012 yılında bizim
için çok önemli bir başarıydı tekrar
jürinin önüne çıktım savunmamı yaptım ve
gururla elektrik ürettiğimizi söyledim
jürinin içerisinden bir sanayici çıkıp
bana şunu söyledi Bu ürettiğin elektrik
ne işe yarayacak şu ampulü yakabiliyor
musun o an durduğum bu kadar çalışmanın
karşılığında böyle bir eleştiriyi hak
etmiyordum dedim ki ampulü Aksam burada
ne işin var ama birlikte işbirliği
yaparsak ampulü de yakabiliriz beraber
orada Tabii ki bir durgunluk oldu
Salonda Bir suskunluk tasarım odaklı
düşünme metodolojisine göre
yaklaştığımızda Aslında
empati kurma aşamasında Biz yeteri kadar
yatırımcıya amacımız yatırım almak ya
yatırımcıyla yeteri kadar iletişim
kurabildik mi yatırımcının Neyi
istediğini tam olarak biliyor muyuz
gözlemledik mi deneyimledik mi konuştuk
mu problemi tanımlama aşamasında problem
bizim problem olarak düşündüğümüz
gerçekten yatırımcının problemi miydi o
dönemde gerçekten öncelikli bir problem
miydi bütün bu
aşamalarını sonunda elimizde bir
prototip vardı ve prototip başarılı bir
prototipti ama bize göre başarılı bir
prototipti mantıken düşündüğümüzde
enerji ile ilgili bir projenin çok rahat
yatırım alması gerekiyordu ama bakış
açısı o dönemki bakış açısı buna el
vermiyordu İzin vermiyordu doktora tez
dönemine geldik ve doktora tez döneminde
danışmanımla istişare ederek tez konumu
belirledik ve ısıtıcı kumaş çalışacaktım
karar vermiştik
ısıtıcı kumaş Yani bir giysi ısıtan
direkt olarak insanı ısıtan bir kumaş
değildi yine bir meydan okuma vardı
kumaşı duvara asacaktınız ve
Bulunduğunuz ortamı Arabanızı evinizde
Odanızı ısıtacaktı projenin
empati kurma problemin tanımlanması
araştırması fikir üretme aşamasına
gelene kadar yani sağlam bir noktaya
gelene kadar tam bir yılımı aldı Çünkü
çok fazla değişken vardı amacımız neydi
ısıyı tek bir noktadan vermek yerine
konforlu bir ısınma sağlamaktı yani
yüzey alanını genişleterek ortamın en
üst noktasından en alt noktasındaki
sıcaklık farkını minimize etmekti
prototipleme ve test etme aşaması iki
buçuk yılımı aldı işin sonunda Hayal
ettiğimizi gerçekleştirdik gerçekten
ciddi bir sıcaklık farkı Yakalayarak
ortamı ısıtan kumaşın prototipini
üretmiştik artık buna endüstri ölçekli
hale getirmek gerekiyordu endüstri
ölçekli hale getirmekte iki buçuk yılımı
aldı Peki endüstri hale getirdikten
sonra her şey bitmiş miydi enerji krizi
artık kapıda değil İçeri girmişti artık
ürünümüzü yenilenebilir enerji
kaynaklarıyla Entegre etmemiz
gerekiyordu her şey çok yolunda gitti
bütün tasarım Odak düşünme
metodolojisinin bütün aşamalarını
uyguladık her şey yolundaydı
endüstrileri ölçekli hale de getirdik
işin sonuna geldiğimizde Neyi gördük
değişimi yakalayamamıştık tekrar yapıyı
güçlendirmemiz gerekiyordu Ve bunu
yaptık 2016 yılında artık doktora bitti
zor bir durumla karşılaştım
3 yaşındaki oğluma otizm teşhisi konuldu
zor bir durumda o dönemde bir anne için
bunu kaldırabilmek bununla beraber
yaşama fikrine kendini alıştırabilmek
Ama şu anda bana bunu sorsanız Size aynı
şeyi söyleyemem derim ki iyi ki O benim
oğlum ve iyi ki ben onun annesiyim beni
ben yaptı Benim hayata bakış açımı
değiştirdi bana Beni başka bir insana
dönüştürdü fotoğraflarda da gördüğünüz
gibi ciddi bir ilerleme kaydettik artık
okuyor yazıyor doğayla bütünleşmiş Doğa
Tutkusu olan okula artık kendi başına
gidebilen topluma artık kazandırılmış
bir çocuk
Peki bunları yapmak kolay oldu mu
bunları yapmak kolay olmadı Tabii ki ilk
teşhis konulduğunda iki buçuk yıl
boyunca uzmanların önerdiği gibi özel
eğitimler tedaviler her şeyi ne
gerekiyorsa yapıldı iki buçuk yılın
sonunda tam Oğlumun doğum gününde Ben
bir sebepten dolayı işten ayrılmak
durumunda kaldım işlerim ayrıldıktan
sonra onu çok rahat gözlemleyebildim ve
dedim ki bunların hiçbirinin hiçbir
faydası yok kolları sıvamak zorundayım
kaybedecek hiçbir şeyim yok O günden
sonra günde 8 saat olmak üzere ciddi
çalışarak bireysel eğitimler vermeye
başladım Oğluma bu bireysel eğitimleri
verirken tasarım odaklı düşünme
metodolojisi yine devreye girdi
ilk başta o bireysel eğitimi verebilmem
için onunla empati kurmam gerekiyordu
Yani artık evde ikinci bir otizmli vardı
Ben de otizmliydim otizmli gibi
düşünmeye çalıştım otizmli gibi
davranmaya çalıştım o ne neye bakar
nasıl anlar hepsini anlamaya çalıştım
bunu yaparken bir şeyle karşılaştım
ona hayranlık duymaya başladım
onun mücadelesine hayranlık duymaya
başladım
hep ağaca sarılmış fotoğraflar
görüyorsunuz orada
ağaçları o fotoğraflar özellikle
çektirilmiyor ağaçları kendi arkadaşı
onları da bir birey olarak görüyor bir
arkadaşı olarak görüyor ağaçlarla özel
bir iletişimi var Biz hani diyoruz ya
doğayla bütünleşmeliyiz Doğa dışa bizim
yaşam hakkımız kadar dışarıda gördüğümüz
ağaçların da yaşam hakkı var Onun bu
söylemlere ihtiyacı yok O zaten onları
kendinden biri olarak görüyor Bu
Yaşadığım mucizelerden sadece bir tanesi
çok daha fazlası var problemi tanımlama
aşamasında çok zorlandım Çok karmaşık
bir süreçti problemi tanımlama
aşamasında çocuğunu otizmli çocuğunu
topluma kazandırmış bir gıda mühendisi
araştırmacı bir gıda mühendisi anneyle
birlikte Çalıştım o bana hep şunu
söyledi problemin kaynağına inmeliyiz
otizm sadece nöro gelişimsel bir
bozukluk mu yoksa
başka sebepler de mi var vücudumuzda
yolunda gitmeyen başka neler var
metabolizma problemleri olabilir mi
analizler yaptırılmalı toksik etkiler
beslenme düzeni pesistisiz beslenme
doğal organik beslenme bireysel
eğitimler bütünsel eğitim gölge
öğretmenlik uygulamasının devreye
sokulması
alternatif tedaviler ve nörofiz Bey
bütün bunlara baktığınızda süreç
gerçekten çok karmaşıktı ve biz Çok
çalışarak bunları oturttuk hayatımıza
bir yılımı aldı bunları oturtmak
kendimizi arındırmaya çalıştık bütün
toksik etkilerden ve çok ciddi
etkilerini Gördük o nöro gelişimsel
bozukluk adı altında tanımlanan otizmi
Aslında büyük oranda yenmeyi başardık o
dönemde Artık hayat devam ediyor ve
benim iş hayatına dönmem gerekiyor fakat
8-6 çalışabilecek yani kurumsal bir
firmada 8-6 çalışabilecek durumda
değilim bir çözüm üretmek zorundayım
Arya odaklı çalışıyorum proje od
çalışıyorum neden esnek zamanlı
çalışmayayım dışarıdan proje odaklı
çalışmalara başladım 2019 yılında kendi
firmamı kurdum orada çok farklı projeler
üzerine çalışıyordum çalıştığım
projelerden bir tanesi de pestisisiz
beslenme idi tekstil mühendisiyim ama
Neticede bu alanda Benim de katkı
sağlayabileceğim bir şeyler
olabileceğini düşündüm bir ağacın
altında otururken kafama elma düşmedi
Ama aklıma bir fikir geldi dedim ki biz
hep bütünleşmekten bahsediyoruz Hep
insanları giydirmeye çalışıyoruz buraya
odaklanmışız neden ağaçlara
giydirmeyelim neden hayvanları
giydirmeyelim Eğer bir faydası olacaksa
eğer bir şeyler yapabileceksek neden
yapmayalım Neden olmasın pestisit
gerçekten sadece yediğimiz meyveler
sebzeler yoluyla bize zarar vermiyor
tarım işçilerine zarar veriyor doğadaki
bütün canlılara zarar veriyor toprağı
havaya suya her şeye zarar veriyor Biz
de zehirliyor o zaman bizde ağaçları
giydiririz tam 2 yıl boyunca
önce mevcut kumaşları deneyerek ağaçlar
üzerinde saha denemeleri ile
destekleyerek bir kumaş geliştirdik
kumaş yüzeyinde farklı prosesler
uyguladık ve bu prosese Star sayesinde
yaptığımız denemelerin başarılı
sonuçlandığını fark ettik sonrasında
organik ürünler üreten
geliştiren ve satan bir firmayla
işbirliği yaparak
onlarla saha denemeleri yaptık ve
yaptığımız saha denemelerinde onların
yüzde 50-60 verimlilik kayıplarını yüzde
beşe indirdik geldiğimiz noktadan çok
çok memnunum artık biz %95 verimlilikle
sarımı gerçekleştirebiliyoruz
kumaşımızın etkinliğini ispatladım
refleksoloji alternatif tedavilerden
bahsettim problemi tanımlarken
alternatif tedavilerden bir tanesi
refleksolojiydi refleksoloji nedir önce
oradan başlamam gerekiyor
organlarımızdan
ellerimize ve ayaklarımıza kadar uzanan
Sinir uçları mevcut Bu sinir uçlarını
basınç yoluyla aktive edebilmemiz mümkün
refleksoloji masajından bahsediyorum
Günde 3 kez oğluma refleksoloji masajı
uygulamaya başladık sonra tabii ki Bu
çok yorucu bir hal almaya başladı Ben o
dönemde aynı zamanda proje odaklı
çalışırken değerli hocam Doktor Erkan
işgören'in yolunu açmasıyla
firmalara firmaların Arge ekiplerine
danışmanlık desteği vermeye başladım
danışmanlık desteği verdiğim çorap
firmalarından bir tanesinde her hafta
inovasyon toplantıları yapıyoruz o
inovasyon toplantılarında
refleksolojiden bahsettim Herkes çok
destekledi ekipteki ve dedi ki
refleksoloji çorabı yapalım
reflek teknolojiyi kullanarak
refleksoloji çorabı yapmamız
çok sorun değildi ama yine tasarım
odaklı düşünmede empati kurma aşaması
eksikti Biz kullanıcıyla ne kadar empati
kurabildik kullanıcı refleksoloji
hakkında ne biliyor bunu önce anlamamız
gerekiyordu refleksolojiyi anlatmamız
gerekiyordu kullanıcı gibi
bilinçlendirmek için
çoraplarımıza refleksoloji noktalarını
gösteren baskılar uyguladık ve böyle bir
ürün geliştirdik yer bildiren çorap yer
bildiren çorapta
oğlumu sürekli olarak okula
gönderdiğimde çok merak ediyordum ne
yapıyor ne ediyor ekipte bunu
tartışırken Aslında konuşurken inovasyon
toplantısında onlar da bunu
desteklediler kreşe giden çocukları
çocuklarını Merak ettiklerini söylediler
dedi ki akıllı saatler var Bu akıllı
saatleri çok kolay çıkarabilirsiniz
çorap üretelim çorabı
çıkarmanız çok daha zor çok daha zaman
alıcı takip edebilmek için çok daha
fazla Zaman kazanmış olursunuz ve yer
bildiren çorabı geliştirdik son olarak
nörofifbekten bahsetmek istiyorum
nörofiz Beynimiz Elektrik sinyallerinden
oluşan canlı bir devre ve bu elektrik
sinyallerini takip ederek beynimizde
yolunda gitmeyen olan durumlarla ilgili
fikir alabiliyoruz otizm
dikkat eksikliği disleksi beyin felci
Alzheimer travmatik durumlar pek çok
konuda destek alınabiliyor bu tedavi
metodundan yönteminden elektrotlar
yardımıyla beyninizdeki sinyalleri bir
yazılıma aktarıyorsunuz ve yazılımın
sizi görsel ve işitsel uyaranlarla
yönlendirmesiyle Aslında beyninizi
eğitmiş oluyorsunuz bunu egzersizlerle
de yapabilirsiniz ama egzersizler çok
daha uzun zaman oluyor ancak teknoloji
ile bunu çok daha kısa sürede
yapabiliyorsunuz ve çok ciddi etkileri
var bunun giyilebilir teknoloji hali
mevcut mu evet giyilebilir teknoloji
hali var Ancak yeterli düzeyde değil
Yeteri kadar konforlu değil Biz şu anda
bunu çok daha esnek konforlu hale
getirmeye çalışıyoruz ve geliyorum yine
üniversite sırasına ilk oturduğum anda
yazdığım cümleye bilimin yolundan asla
ayrılmayacağım
Evet ben araştırmacı olmasaydım bilim
tutkum olmasaydı Bütün bunların
üstesinden gelebilir miydim yapabilir
miydim
yollarımızı bilimin ışığı daima
aydınlatsın
geleceğimizi
bilimin ışığı yönlendirsin Sevgiyle
kalın Çok teşekkürler